مع دخول حرب إسرائيل مع حماس
شهرها الثاني،
لم يتضح بعد ما الذي سيحدث عندما تنتهي الحرب، أثار رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو
الدهشة في وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع عندما قال
إن إسرائيل بحاجة إلى أن تكون مسؤولة عن
أمن غزة لفترة غير محددة
لمنع المستقبل.  الهجمات على إسرائيل
منذ ذلك الحين أوضح المسؤولون الإسرائيليون
تعليقه قائلين إنه
لن يكون إعادة احتلال، وما زالت الولايات المتحدة
تقول إن الوجود طويل الأمد ليس
فكرة جيدة أه لا يمكن أه أن تستمر غزة في
إدارتها من قبل حماس أه واضح أيضًا
أن  إسرائيل لا تستطيع أن تحتل غزة أم الآن
الواقع أنه قد تكون هناك أه
حاجة لبعض الفترة الانتقالية أه في
نهاية الصراع ولكن من
الضروري أن أه
الشعب الفلسطيني أه يكون مركزيا في أه الحكم
أه في أه في غزة وفي  الضفة الغربية
أيضًا أه وهذا مرة أخرى أه لا نرى
أه إعادة احتلال
لذلك إذا كانت إسرائيل ستكون
مسؤولة عن الأمن فقط فمن الذي
سيحكم غزة بالضبط، إنه سؤال
يطرح مرارًا وتكرارًا أه مثلك
تذكروا أن إسرائيل انسحبت من
القطاع في عام 2005، وكان الجناح السياسي لحماس هو
المسؤول منذ عام 2007 بعد
طرد فتح، وكانت هناك
اقتراحات بأن الأمم المتحدة أو ربما حتى
السلطة الفلسطينية يمكن أن تتدخل،
ولكن لا يعد أي خيار شعبيًا، لذا حان الوقت
الآن  التبادل الذي انضم إلينا
مارك ريف، أحد كبار مستشاري
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو،
مرحباً بك في البرنامج، شكرًا لك على
الوقت الذي أمضيته، والآن نعلم أن هناك
بعض التوضيحات من حكومتك
بشأن ما كان رئيس الوزراء
يشير إليه بأنه قد يكون هناك  أن تكون سيطرة
أمنية مؤقتة على غزة من قبل إسرائيل ولكن
فيما يتعلق بمن سيحكم غزة
بصرف النظر عن القول إنها لن تكون حماس،
ليس لدينا إجابة محددة من
الإسرائيليين واليوم سمعنا من
وزير الخارجية الأمريكي نوعاً ما  من
أقرب إشارة إلى موقف الولايات المتحدة من
هذا الأمر،
استمع إلينا، ويجب علينا أيضًا أن نعمل على
العناصر الإيجابية للتوصل إلى
سلام مستدام، ويجب أن تشمل هذه العناصر
أصوات الشعب الفلسطيني
وتطلعاته في قلب حكم ما بعد الأزمة
في غزة، ويجب أن تشمل
الفلسطينيين.  الحكم أه وغزة
موحد مع الضفة الغربية في ظل
السلطة الفلسطينية ويجب أن
يتضمن آلية مستدامة لإعادة
الإعمار في غزة ومسار
للإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين الذين يعيشون جنبا إلى
جنب في دول خاصة بهم
بمقاييس متساوية من الأمن والحرية
والفرص
والكرامة  لذلك سمعناه يقول إنه ينبغي
توحيد غزة مع الضفة الغربية في ظل
السلطة الفلسطينية بمجرد انتهاء الحرب، وهو
الموقف الذي
توافق عليه إسرائيل، وهل تعتقد أنه
يمكن الصمود فيه في ضوء ما رأيناه في
عام 2007 بعد طرد السلطة الفلسطينية فعليًا
خارج غزة، كيف يمكنك تجنب
انقلاب آخر إذا عادت السلطة الفلسطينية؟
أعني أنك أثرت بعض
النقاط المهمة للغاية لأنه كما
قلت للتو، عندما انسحبت إسرائيل من
قطاع غزة في عام 2005، تم تسليمه إلى
السلطة الفلسطينية لكنهم فقدوا
السلطة  إلى كاماس بعد فترة وجيزة
وحكمت حماس
منذ 16 عامًا من حكم حماس وما الذي
اشترته لشعب غزة من
المعاناة والألم
والفقر، لذا فمن الواضح أنه عندما ينتهي هذا الأمر
ويتوقف عن إدارة قطاع غزة ستكون هناك
فرص  أعتقد أنه
بالنسبة لسكان غزة الذين لم يكونوا موجودين قبل
الفرص المهمة كما قلت،
إلا أن إسرائيل ليست مهتمة
فقط بترك الأمور تنهار
بعد أن ندمر حماس، علينا أن
نتأكد من أن الوضع الأمني
مستقر وعلينا أن نجعله  من المؤكد أنه
لا يوجد أي عنصر إرهابي متبقي
يبدأ في النمو مرة أخرى، ولن
تتمكن إسرائيل من تجاهل ما يجري في غزة